let's talk about the online dating space
you had mentioned you know you're you're
not really dating at this point you're
in a longer term relationship but you
had said in the past like you would meet
these women online what's your just
overall thoughts and Impressions on the
on the dating Marketplace online and is
this a good place for guys to go if
they're single obviously you got to go
where they are right so yeah this's kind
of open up that box there yeah I've got
a chapter in my book that that
essentially talks about how to get girls
online because it's because it's
probably the most convenient and easy
way for guys to meet uh women the
problem is though is that most guys
haven't done anything with their life
like they haven't leveled themselves up
you know most men when I talk to them
and they're struggling with you know
their dating life I'll ask them on a
scale of 1 to 10 where do you rate
yourself and they're like four five you
know maybe a six you know most of the
time and they're being reasonably honest
and you know the truth of the matter is
is that when you look at the stats on
the way women behave online and because
of their hypergamous nature women always
want a data cross and up on a social
economic scale they don't want to data
cross and down they want to be with
somebody better like I said earlier they
want to be with a giant so the vast
major major of men that are out there
right now like it's never been easier to
stand out from the crowd the vast
majority of guys that women are coming
across on things like dating apps are
mostly plugged in beta Mals right uh
they're the kind of guys that are like
well you know well where do you want to
meet and what time do you want to meet
and you know like on what day of the
week do you want to meet sort of thing
and they'll leave it all in their court
and these chicks are
like another one of these bozos and they
just sort of like ghost them or they
show a lot like low interest or
disinterest and these guys get
frustrated they don't get what they want
so if you're good like if you have some
game if you're a good-look guy you've
got some style you've got your life
sorted away like you're at least a seven
or eight out of 10 like maybe even have
some a little bit of room for
improvement then use dating apps and
you'll do well but if you're not in that
top percentile you're going to have a
very difficult time you're going to get
ghosted you're not going to get a lot of
matches you're going to get disinterest
you're going to get women that are
indifferent you know to you they're
going to cancel they're going to flake
you're going to have all kinds of
problems you're going to get frustrated
and you know like there's not a lot of
great women out there that are long-term
relationship ship type of material in
North America anyway like the vast
majority of women that are out there
like as they get older they carry around
a lot of baggage and Trauma from the
past one in five women are on ssris or
anti-depressants uh they're over they're
overly entitled they're bratty they
think that they're a 10 when they're
really A four they're obese they're
covered in tattoos like there's all
kinds of problems that you can you know
they're they're feminists they've got uh
bad attitude you know the patriarchy
oppressing them with everything like you
hear all these narratives and it's like
the the only way that you're going to
get past all of that because you got to
dig through a lot of dirt to find gold
is if you're a topshelf guy because
that's what all the women want they want
to select the best that they can get
because of their hypergamous nature so
if you want to do well online dating
you'll do very well hypergamy is a great
thing for you if you're a topshelf man
yeah I think I think 20% of the men
online are are are competing for 80% of
of the women and vice versa I think the
average woman swipes right about 4% of
the time yeah would you then say you
know we have a lot of younger guys that
are listening to this our audience is
kind of split I think I told you there
at the beginning so there's a lot of
guys that are kind of in their 20s
they're at this point in life where like
their opportunity to grow Excel Chase
greatness is actually right in front of
them and I would advise a lot of these
guys focus on yourself like take a
season of whether you want to call it
monk mode take a season of isolation
build yourself up becom in the 20% so
would that be advice that you would give
to maybe a younger guy out there like if
he's if he's Ling himself as a four five
six like become an eight become a nine
and then where should he begin to focus
on if he is trying to ascend that ladder
into the top 20% well the two most
important areas to get the attention of
like if you want women to be with you
and men to look at you and want to be
you you've got to you've got to have the
Optics of masculinity and strength
sorted out and you've got to have your
money squared away because men are
success sorry men are success objects
right women are Beauty objects men are
success objects so we're very different
so one of the great lies that Society
tells us is that men and women are
exactly the same and that's like the
furthest thing from the truth we saw
that uh lose I can't remember his name
Lena something is a name that he adopted
in his swimming career but he was like
uh rated like 400 against men when he
was a male swimmer and then he went into
the women's category and he dominated
and got all the medals right so um men
and women are not the same we're very
very different and I think that the
earlier a guy can understand and adopt
that uh truth um and they focus on
themselves and they like what is it it's
something like 43% of men in North
America are considered obese like all
you have to do is not be fat like start
there
um and then you know if that's where
you're at right now then get a gym
membership and work on you know the
Optics of a Vaper because broad
shoulders wide shoulders in a narrow
waist getting you the 1.62 golden ratio
uh which I talk about in my book as well
is what women prefer like that's what
they have historically selected mates on
and having money and resources is super
important too because look I mean if
you're 20 and she's 19 or something like
that and you're dating in that rate it
doesn't matter if you have wealth right
like it's it's not that significant but
as women get older and more mature and
you know they're they're looking to
check out of the dating uh landscape and
maybe have kids or settle down or
whatever um they're looking for a guy
that's that's competent in the sense
that he can make it rain like you know
he's got access to financial resources
because women can't be you know working
when they're taking care of a baby yeah
absolutely man it's it's never been
easier to be separated fitness-wise like
he said you know like just get in the
gym and don't be don't be ort of that
40% that is that is obese and I would
say
today's world it's never been easier to
make six like you don't need to be a
like you don't think you need to be a
millionaire but I mean a you know six
fig income I would say is very easily
attainable for every guy out there would
you agree I I tell guys aim to be a
millionaire by the time you're 30 if you
don't hit 30 at least do it by 40 like
it's incumbent on you especially if
you're in North America and you'd be
shocked at the amount of push back that
I get from that oh Rich doesn't
understand how the world Works he's
disconnected he inherited Silver Spoon
all this all this [__] and it's like
if that's your mindset if that's what
you think of yourself then you're always
going to be a loser right winners never
quit quitters never win and if you're
and if you're seeing yourself from the
gecko as somebody that can accomplish
something um and I'm not going to use
the word simple but as reasonable as
acquiring a million dollars in in net
worth I'm sorry you're just not going to
do great in life I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the Channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out